lisa owns a random candy vending machine
which is a machine that picks a candy
out of an assortment in a random fashion
lisa controls the probability in which
each candy is picked she is running out
of honey bunny so she wants to program
its probability so that the probability
of getting a different candy twice in a
row is greater than two and one-fourth
times the probability of getting honey
bunny in one try so let me read that
again
she wants to program its probability so
that the probability of getting a
different candy twice in her or really
any other candy twice in a row is
greater than two and one-fourth times
the probability of getting honey bunny
in one try write an inequality that
models the situation use p to represent
the probability of getting honey bunny
in one try solve the inequality and
complete the sentence remember that the
probability must be a number between
zero and one so we want to write the
inequality that models a problem here
and then we want to complete the
sentence the probability of getting
honey bunny in one try must be so they
give us a bunch of options greater than
greater than or equal to less than less
than or equal to and then we have to put
some number here so to work through this
I've copy and pasted this problem onto
my little scratch pad right over here
and so let's just think about it a
little bit so they tell us use P to
represent the probability of getting
honey bunny in one try and they also say
she wants to program his probability so
that the probability of getting a
different candy twice in a row is
greater than 2 and 1/4 the probability
of getting honey bunny in one try
so what's if P is the probability of
getting honey bunny P is the probability
of getting honey bunny what's the
probability of getting any other any
other candy at once well that's going to
be one minus P if you have a probability
of P of getting honey bunny
well that is 1 minus P of anything but
honey bunny now what's the probability
of getting this twice in a row getting
anything else twice in a row well you're
just going to multiply this probability
times itself it's going to be 1 minus P
times
- pee or we could just write that as 1
minus P squared so this right over here
is the probability of getting a
different candy any other candy twice in
a row
so prob of any any other non honey-bunny
candy other any other candy twice in in
a row now they tell us that this needs
to be greater than this probability
needs to be greater than two and
one-fourth times the probability - and
1/4 so probability of getting honey
bunny in one time in one try so 2 is
greater than 2 and 1/4 - and 1/4 times
the probability of getting honey bunny
in one try well that is P times P so we
have just set up the first part we have
written an inequality that models the
situation now let's actually solve this
inequality and so to do that I will just
expand 1 minus P squared out 1 minus P
squared is the same thing as P squared
is the same thing as is the same well
I'll just multiply it out so this is
going to be 1 squared 1 squared minus 2p
plus P squared and that's going to be
greater than 2 and 1/4 P greater than 2
and 1/4 P now let's see if we subtract
we subtract 2 and 1/4 P from both sides
we're going to be left with and I'm
going to reorder this we're going to get
P squared so you have minus 2 P minus 2
and 1/4 P so that's going to give us
minus 4 and 1/4 P R let me just write
that as 17 over 4 P plus 1 plus 1 is
greater than greater than 0 is greater
than 0 and so let's think about let's
think about solving this quadratic right
over here and under which circumstances
is this greater than 0
think about it let's factor it and
actually before we factor it let's
simplify it a little bit I don't like
having this seventeen fourth right over
here so let's multiply both sides times
four and since 4 is a positive number
it's not going to change the sign of the
direction of this inequality so we could
rewrite this as 4p squared minus 17 P
plus four plus four is is greater than
zero is greater than zero and let's see
what are the roots of this and we could
use the quadratic formula if we wanted
to do it really quick we could probably
do it other ways but negative B so it's
going to be 17 plus or minus the square
root the square root of of 17 negative
17 squared B squared so that's 289 minus
4 times a times C well a times C is 16
times 4 so minus 64 all of that over 2
times a all of that over 8 so that's 17
plus or minus let's see this is the
square root of 225 over 8 which is equal
to 17 plus or minus 15 over 8 which is
equal to well let's see 17 minus 15 over
8 is 2 8 which is equal to two eighths
or 1/4 so that's one of them that's that
when we take the minus and if we add 17
plus 15 that gets us to 32 divided by 8
is 4 or 4 so there's two situations
right over here so we could let's let's
factor this out we could write this as P
minus 1/4 times P minus 4 is greater
than is greater than 0 so under what
circumstances is is this going to be
true what constraints are this going to
be true well if you're taking the
product
of two terms and they are going to be
greater than zero that means that these
two things have to be the same sign or
actually in particular they both have to
be positive or they both have to be
negative so let's look at those two
situations so I'll switch colors here
just for fun so both positive or both
both negative so if they're both
positive that means that P we do it here
that means that P minus 1/4 has to be
greater than 0 and P minus 4 is greater
than 0
add 1/4 on both sides right over here
you get P is greater than is greater
than 1/4 and P P is greater than 4 so
that's the situation where they are both
positive now what about if they're both
negative well then you have P minus 1/4
is less than 0 and P minus 4 is less
than 0 add 1/4 here so P needs to be
less than 1/4 and P needs to be less
than it needs to be less than 4 now what
do what does this expression what is
this constraint simplify to P has to be
greater than 1/4 and P has to be greater
than 4 well if P is greater than 4 it's
definitely going to be greater than 1/4
so all of this collapses into P needs to
be greater than 4 that's the situation
where both are positive P must be
greater than 4 now what about here
well if P is less than 1/4 it's
definitely going to be less than 4 and
this is an end right over here so this
collapse is 2 P is less than P is less
than 1/4 so which one do we go with P
needs to be greater than 4 or P needs to
be less than 1/4 well we need to remind
ourselves that we're talking about a
probability
back to the original problem we're
talking about a probability of someone
getting honey bunny in one try
probability must be between 0 and 1 so
the probability being having to be
greater than 4 well that just doesn't
make any sense that doesn't make any
sense in the context of this question so
we have to go with the probability of
getting honey and honey bunny needs to
be less than 1/4 or less than 0.25 which
makes complete sense so let's fill in
this information this was this was the
inequality that modeled that modeled the
problem and we got P has to be less than
1/4 so let's go back to the original
problem the inequality was 1 minus P
squared 1 minus P squared needs to be
greater than 2 and 1/4 so we could write
that multiple times I could write that
as 2 point 2 5 times P and then the
probability of getting honey bunny in
one try
must be less than less than 0.25 and
we're done